(fireworks exploding)
- Stretching way back to my childhood,
I wanted to understand time.
(indistinct chatter)
Being shown the stars through a telescope
and told that what I was seeing
was thousands of years in the past,
to me, it was a mystery,
the ebbs and flows of time.
(clock ticking)
My name is Jem Finer, and
I've composed Long Player,
which is an everlasting piece of music
that repeats every thousand years.
Long Player started
playing at the beginning
of the year 2000.
Around the middle of the 1990's,
the millennium started
to be discussed a lot,
but really, all that was being discussed
were very short-term
ways of celebrating it.
A few nights of fireworks and parties.
It seemed to me there's
a kind of absurdity about
celebrating something so long
by strategies that were so short.
So one of the things that interested me
is making this thousand years tangible.
It occurred to me one day
that the best way I can do that
was to write a piece of music.
(bowl ringing)
If you imagine taking six
copies of the same record
and playing them on six
different turn tables.
So you spin each turn
table at a different speed.
You're moving through the
material at different points
on each one, and in that
way you get a relationship
that never resolves, never
comes back into phase,
until exactly after a thousand years.
(ringing bowl)
So what these singing bowls are here,
are all the bowls that are necessary
to play any point of Long Player
in its thousand year long duration.
You think a singing bowl
has just this ballad,
you just hit it and it sounds,
but actually they're very complex.
It's like there's all
sorts of sounds in there
that you can tease out in different ways.
The future of Long Player
could go many different ways.
You don’t what's going to happen
technologically, politically,
culturally, ecologically.
It creates this continuum of people,
a community of listeners and caretakers
across generations until
the 31st of December, 2999,
at which point it will get
back to where it first started,
and start again.
(ethereal music)